Will technology revolutionize schooling?
Past efforts should leave us weary: the story
of ed tech is one of over-promising
and under-delivering. To break this cycle,
we need to pay more attention to what
educators actually do with education
technology. Yet major surveys of ed tech
use seem more interested in marketing
than in making it work. Americans are
asked whether technology makes learning
"easier and more fun," or whether they
think "AI could make a positive impact in
the world of education." Teachers get
asked whether "using digital learning
tools helps [them] teach more effectively."
And honestly, whatever the truth, are you
going to be the Luddite who says "No"?
A better suggestion: Ask teachers how much
time they spent dealing with
uncooperative technology, or whether
their districts consider teacher input
when deciding what to buy. Digital learning
has great promise, but achieving
it requires tending to the gritty reality,
rather than uncritical cheerleading.
Have you seen an example of where
school technology actually got in the
way of learning? Let us know in our poll.
Also let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.